it's time now for one more thing jesse
this is a very special day and i think
we know the reason judge oh happy
birthday
[Applause]
happy birthday judge
very happy birthday and to celebrate how
amazing you are we put together a little
montage some of your best moments oh no
okay here's the bottom line here's the
bottom line here's the deal and that's
all i have to say and that's all i have
to say all right now it's my turn
okay stop breath stop now they disrupt
me all the time
what the hell is going on
this is
did you call me george for those of you
who know me i love candy now so i have
some of my favorite york peppermint
patties every time i eat one of these i
have the sensation of a cool breeze
blowing through my hair and the wind
across my long flowing dress
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't rush speaking of sweets
i think we have some sweets right here
the yellow cake there it is i love you
i'm not eating any of it yes you are
okay thank you
okay all right speaking of sweets oh no
it's going to be a sweet hour of prime
time tonight at seven o'clock we have
the president addressing the nation
on guns at 7 30 so check out our
coverage there's this cake we baked a
gun in there judge yeah i think craig no
gun jokes okay greg your turn okay uh
tonight great show i got kaylee mcaday i
got chris baron cat tim times it's going
to be a barn burner again don't burn any
barns let's do this
greg's job search as you know a few
months ago i joined linkedin because i
wanted to hunt down somebody that had
done me wrong
they had me put down what i did for a
living and i wrote down host and now i'm
getting all these notices for job
openings and here's my third installment
of them they're hiring as a host for
olive garden and the uh and you create
the guest's first and lasting impression
it's worth it bottomless pit of whatever
hershey park fun crew
i get to enjoy creating moments of
surprise and delight for guests around
hershey park that one i would treat
seriously
um last uh wendy's crew member was not
really into wendy's uh the little the
little girl used to freak me out but you
have to greet each guest with a smile
and a warm welcome and you you should be
able to multitask i don't qualify on the
warm welcome no i don't finally of
course sorry jessica your turn this is
the most delicious cake isn't it i don't
yeah it's really good okay because i
guess all i talk about is babies um here
we go
an australian mother has an interesting
approach to feeding her baby her young
daughter was refusing plastic bottles as
she tried to transition her from
breastfeeding and after noticing that
the baby was receptive to drinking from
a plastic syringe she had the idea of
putting formula in a clean tomato sauce
bottle and voila she took to it
instantly so if you're struggling with
your baby
try a tomato sauce bottle wow the
formula does wow yeah australians okay
real fast have you ever wondered what it
was like to move into an apartment in
new york city colonel a great dane from
boston figured it out providing you an
example of how the experience typically
goes all colonel has to say is he's
unimpressed can someone get him a bigger
bed that's it for us special report is
up next break you want something thank
you judge here's the deal
have a very very happy birthday and
that's all i have to say about it thank
you
thank you thanks for the cake
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now